[Music]
our government is representative and
that means we don't do it ourselves so
if you're gonna understand the form of
our government which form is unique
you'll have to understand something
that's in the decoration independence is
a precursor and that thing is consent or
consent of the government so then the
argument would have to go like this that
there's such a thing as a human that all
the things that are like that are equal
in some respect
the dis equality sets them up to be
governed rightly only by their consent
and that gives rise to the structures of
the Constitution so to connect all those
things up is to retrace the steps of the
American Revolution why consent what is
consent and why it's kind of more or
less a social contract that both parties
are agreeing to the terms and conditions
we as the people being governed are
allowing those who are in power to look
over and provide the necessary
securities so we can as they put to
pursue our happiness so in the
declaration opinions what did they say
about the social contract it's
referenced in the laws of nature and
nature's gone music where well the
social contract assumes that there are
laws of nature because you enter into
the social contract you're leaving the
state of nature it sounds a bit like
John Locke who talks about that a whole
bunch and so we have to we have to be
careful not to get to chasing our own
tails and so we might stick with just
something direct and simple and
understandable right like if we're equal
you wouldn't have the authority to do
something to me unless I say so
whereas the king answered the
Declaration of Independence did you know
that he gave an address from the throne
and he gave an answer cause
this answer this address from thorough
knee caused it to be distributed across
the lines at the siege of Boston and he
basically said in there I was born to be
the king here and you were born to be
the subjects and I am required to look
after you and be good to you and take
care of you and to do what's in your
interest what's good for you but you are
required to do what I say and he thought
that that would turn the whole thing
around and at the moment that he
distributed this thing across the lines
to the Continental Army
it was melting away because their their
enlistments were up and they read that
thing and they went what is that what he
thinks we're gonna where's that we're
gonna do this thing right the King's
idea is that I was born with an
obligation and you were born with an
obligation we both have to do our thing
and we're born that way and the
different said of Penance denies that it
says we're all born equal equal in that
sense that I named right we're not dogs
until the dogs start talking so that's
what they say and if it's like that then
you get to be our king if we say so
there's a really great document that
we're not reading in this course but I
encourage everyone to read it in our
Constitution reader is written by Thomas
Jefferson who of course was a very
powerful writer earth-shaking Lee
powerful writer wrote the deck for some
independence and it's called a summary
view of the rights of British North
America and in there he goes on and on
and on and he explains you get to be the
king if we say so you have to do what we
say in the last paragraph which I'll
paraphrase he says that let those
flattered who fear it is not an American
art your counselors are partisans not
drawn from us right so he's telling the
King what for
you know and it gives rise soon
you know the flag with the snake that
says don't tread on me we have a right
we are born the same as you you get your
carriage since you got it already it's
just that that you don't get to tell us
what to do from it consent is born in
equality in that way right and and just
you just have to remember that we
Americans we just breathe that from
birth we get that with Mother's Milk you
know that's what we think we think we're
born equal it's the reason why we think
we can do whatever we want if we work
hard enough
it's the reason I thought you know I
grabbed my dad's a school teacher from
Pocahontas Arkansas right but I didn't
know that that wasn't the grandest thing
in the world to be I knew we weren't
rich but I didn't think anybody was born
better than I nor I better than anybody
else
Churchill life you should love to say
about equality he'd say yeah it's the
principle that everybody is as good as
everybody else or a little better would
you like that the church it was very
witty
so so now if you're gonna have consent
that's a very radical thing to think the
King of England didn't think that right
the fact that he gave that address from
the throne and had it distributed he
thought that would be persuasive right
later they'd send Ben Franklin who was
let's call it let's say a very artful
human being we all know what that means
right for example he was the world's
greatest spokesman for for pious
middle-class morality anyway they sent
him to England to negotiate he didn't
get on whether they liked him better in
Paris he went there too
and he gets over there and he talks with
the cabinet and the cabinet says we are
the
other country and you are the children
and you must do what we say and he
writes a letter back to the to the
Continental Congress and says this is
gonna be a war because what they think
is and remember what they think is what
everybody thinks it's what the King of
France thinks who later subsidized our
revolution it's what they all think it's
what the world has thought from time
immemorial and these guys don't think
that that's a remarkable development in
human history and what we're going to
talk about now is the amazing things
that that makes possible this idea of
consent you see if they can only do it
to you if you say so then incredible
things become possible in arranging
government
you
[Music]